Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to learn how to take any
shape in the real world, make a digital copy
of it, and place it into our virtual world.
These can be done through something that we
call differentiable rendering.
What is that?
Well, simple, we take a photograph, and find
a photorealistic material model that we can
put into our light simulation program that
matches it.
What this means is that now, we can essentially
put this real material into a virtual world.
This work did very well with materials, but,
it did not capture the geometry.
This other work is from Wenzel Jakob’s group
and it jointly found the geometry and material
properties.
Seeing these images gradually morph into the
right solution is an absolutely beautiful
sight.
But, as you see high-frequency details were
not as good.
You see here - these details are gone.
So, where does this put us?
If we need only the materials, we can do really
well, but then, no geometry.
If we wish to get the geometry and the materials,
we can use this, but we lose a lot of detail.
There seems to be no way out.
Is there a solution for this?
Well, Wenzel Jakob’s amazing light transport
simulation group is now back with guns blazing!
Let’s see what they were up to.
Let’s try to reproduce a 3D geometry from
a bunch of triangles.
Let’s see….and.
Ouch.
Not good, right?
So what is the problem here?
The problem is that we have tons of self-intersections,
leading to a piece of tangled mesh geometry.
This is incorrect.
Not what we are looking for.
Now, let’s try to improve this apply a step
that we call regularization, this guides the
potential solutions towards smoother results.
Sounds good, hoping that this will do the
trick.
Let’s have a look together.
So, what do you think?
Better, but there are some details that are
lost, and my main issue is that the whole
geometry is in fluctuation.
Is that a problem?
Yes it is.
Why?
Because this jumpy behavior means that it
has many competing solutions that it can’t
choose from.
Essentially, the algorithm says, maybe this,
or not…perhaps this instead, no, not this.
How about this?
And it just keeps going on forever.
It doesn’t really know what makes a good
reconstruction.
Now, hold on to your papers, and let’s see
how the new method does with these examples.
Oh my!
This converges somewhere, which means that
at the end of the process, it settles on something.
Finally, this one knows what good is.
Fantastic.
But now, these geometries were not that difficult.
Let’s give it a real challenge!
Here comes the dragon.
Can it deal with that?
Just look at how beautifully it grows out
of this block.
Yes, but, look - the details are not quite
there.
So, are we done?
That’s it?
No!
Not even close!
But, do not despair for a second!
This new paper also proposes an isotropic
remeshing step, which does…this!
On the count of one, two, three.
Boom, we are done.
Whoa!
So good.
And, get this, the solution is not restricted
to only geometry, it also works on textures.
Now, make no mistake, this is not super useful
in its current state, but it may pave a way
to even more sophisticated methods two more
papers down the line.
So, importing real geometry into our virtual
worlds.
Yes please!
Thanks for
watching and for your generous support, and
I'll see you next time!